cinéma ça tombe plutôt bien les enfants
sont gâtés en ce moment les films
d'animation sont très réussis tarzan
les géants de faire et mon voisin totoro
ce dernier film et japonais une histoire
d'amitié entre deux fillettes et une
étrange créature nathalie hutter n'ai
pas peur mais je suis attaqué deux
paquets rien tu vois bien dans cette
maison dans cette maison et surtout dans
ce jardin un jardin extraordinaire
peuplé de créatures étranges les taux
tout seul les enfants peuvent les voies
pour mailler cette subite les herbes
folles de leur nouveau lieu de vie
deviennent bientôt un monde parallèle et
totalement irrésistible c'est tout
yazaki c'est un cas particulier dans
l'animation mondiale hirson le pas aux
autres japonais ça rien de manga ça n'a
rien de violent qui s'intéressent à
dessin très pur très clair et très
simple comme ça en fait c'est un dessin
animé qui procède une étude de la nature
très poussée les décors sont toujours
très très soigné et cetera son juste
esquissé
on est plus proche du dessin japonais
18ème 19ème siècle que l'animation
générale
témoin il y a deux thèmes auxquels j'ai
constamment penser en composant la
musique de ce film est d'abord l'amour
de la nature et ensuite à tendresse de
l'être humain
p
aime la nature et la nature tout le
rendra le message est on ne peut plus
simple et miyazaki la teinte d'humour et
de poésie
de quoi faire de mon voisin totoro un
film en en chanteur que les enfants
comme les adultes ne seront pas prêts
d'oublier